from the netflix series bling empire to
getting her very first residency dj
residency at the win kim lee is on fire
jillian talked with her about being a
female dj how reality tv has changed her
life and what her favorite thing about
las vegas is check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
hi kim lee we're so excited to have you
coming back out to vegas this is now
like your home away from home how does
it feel to have a residency at xf
oh my goodness uh
it's surreal to me i i first off i love
vegas who doesn't like vegas right um
having a residency in vegas
is a dream come true and not just that
you know being at the wind is like whoa
i mean from the energy the atmosphere
there i mean it's next level there so
i'm just really blessed and happy to be
there
you're a female dj you're obviously in a
male dominated industry but how does it
feel to represent women and i feel like
it's on the rise but we're still you
know kind of waiting but you have like
really broken through and made a name
for yourself yeah um i get so many
females at my show more than ever and
especially them coming up to me saying
you're a huge inspiration um
it makes me feel really happy to hear
that that um
that a lot of girls are like you know
i'm
i want to be a dj too and for me to to
be able to be such a huge influence on
them it's like it makes me feel really
good it makes me feel like all right i'm
on the right path
and um
i'm very supportive other females i'm
all saying like hey
just keep going believe in your dream
and stay focused now you can be an
inspiration to anyone else out there who
wants to to follow their dreams and in
your footsteps and yeah let's talk about
bling empire for a minute because
obviously it's probably great for you
too getting even more of a following and
introducing people into what you do but
what's it been like to really welcome
everyone into your personal life
um it hasn't been easy i'm not gonna lie
at first you know when i first started i
was
i was like oh this is gonna be fun you
know if you're gonna follow my life and
i realized like whoa
don't get me wrong it's fun but it's
hard
to really open your life up and getting
judged from the world and since we are
local in las vegas we always just like
to ask like what's your favorite thing
about the city what do you love most
about vegas you know what's entertaining
people watching in vegas is so much fun
people i can literally
i wish i had time to just like sit and
watch people because they're so
entertaining you know what i mean um you
get people from all over the world well
can we congratulations this is your
moment we're so excited to have you part
of our vegas community and with some
other dates coming up throughout the
summer so we'll be seeing a lot of you i
hope to see you at one of my shows guys
i'll come find you if i come
you can see kim lee at wynn tonight and
then again on june 10th and june 17th
for the full lineup visit
wynitelife.com
all right jc so